it's known as earth's evil twin venus
gives us a glimpse into both our past
and our future a past where water formed
and perhaps life arose before it did on
earth and our future where earth will
heat up so venus is a fascinating place
to look at earth in a mirror the two
planets are close in age size and makeup
but unlike earth venus evolved into a
kind of toxic wasteland it lost its
surface water and became hot enough to
melt lead so what happened researchers
are hoping to answer that question and
whether venus may have once been
brimming with life with three new
missions to the hot planet
they will offer the entire science
community the chance to investigate a
planet
we haven't been to in more than 30 years
in those 30 years much of the attention
has gone to mars
mars is not like earth and venus mars is
much smaller it's only about about 4 7
the size of earth venus turns out to be
the other planet in our solar system
which is the most earth-like but yet a
horrible fate has befallen venus dr
darby dyer is among a group of
scientists working on the new missions
to venus she's part of the scientific
leadership team for one called veritas
and it's set to launch at the end of the
decade the spacecraft will take a census
of the rock types on venus that data is
essential for understanding what
happened to venus and if it hosted life
where it might have been imagine that
sometime in the last billion years earth
was completely covered by basalt
the only thing that would stick up from
the basaltic ocean if that happened
would be the continents the high places
so it's sort of like the noah's ark on a
planet basalt are dark fine-grained
rocks that kind of line the ocean floors
here on earth continents are made up
mostly of a different kind of rock
called granite which is lighter
scientists are interested in granites
because they form in the presence of
water a key molecule for life on venus
those are the two primary rocks that
veritas wants to locate in id
and it's going to try to do that as it
orbits venus
it's staggering to me that we know so
little about the surface of venus and
what that means is that anything we find
with these missions is going to be
really amazing and exciting and first of
its kind that huge undertaking comes
down in part to this sensor before
launch dyer and her collaborators are
training the device in its machine
learning brains on earth rocks let's
take a look at how that process works
first dyer collected a diverse set of
rocks then they were cut
and ground
the samples are then sent to a lab at
the german aerospace center in berlin
there researchers heat up the rock chips
to more than 800 degrees fahrenheit
in this so-called venus chamber
it's meant to mimic the surface
temperatures on the planet at such high
temperatures rocks heat up so much that
they glow
the kind of light they give off depends
on what the rocks are made of dark
basalts emit more light than lighter
granites
that light is captured by the prototype
veritas sensor through a special kind of
glass window on the venus chamber
eventually when veritas reaches venus
its sensors will scan the planet and
compare the new data to rocks that
studied here on earth
the geological process processes act the
same and therefore the rock types we are
fairly confident are going to be the
same if veritas can map out granite
formations on venus that could help
scientists figure out where to send
future landers to narrow down the search
for signs of life habitability that's
the endgame
not only do we care about habitability
on earth and venus but we also care
about the habitability of objects in
other solar systems throughout the
universe which are called exoplanets and
if there are other earth and venus-like
objects out there then maybe we're not
alone and that's a really important
question that we really love to
understand
you